[Musique]
les jeux olympiques de tokyo ont
commencé à ce vendredi à 23 juillet et
dehimi loire sont en course pour
remporter des médailles après une
semaine de compétition bixente est ce
que les yvelinois ont performé sur cette
compétition et bien michael c'était
plutôt en demi-teinte à ya du bon et du
moins bon qu'hier beauvais en argent
déjà c'est la performance yvelinoise de
la semaine la rameuse licencié à
mantes-la-jolie monte sur la deuxième
marche du podium avec sa coéquipière
laura taranto là une première médaille
pour l'aviron français féminin depuis
1996 autres médailles en argent
également celle d'astrid guyart en
fleuret par équipes au terme d'une
demi-finale ponctuée d'une remontée
d'anthologie face à l'italie et d'une
finale perdue contre la russie
l'escrimeuse originaire du vésinet son
équipe viennent apporter à la france sa
première médaille dans cette âme depuis
35 ans une très belle performance à
milliers également des déceptions à sur
ces jeux olympiques pour l'instant pour
les bmx notamment avec eux les pilotes
qui s'entraînent juste à côté au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
libye et oui pas de médaille
malheureusement pour le bmx pensée nous
avions pourtant du monde en finale 1
avec quatre tricolores trois sur le
tableau masculin une sur le féminin
alors que sylvain andré termine lui à la
quatrième marche du podium
la déception sera surtout pour joris
daudet qui pensaient arracher une
médaille de bronze avant de chuter dans
le dernier virage
déception également pour maiva
hamadouche éliminé dès le premier tour
des moins de 60 kg en boxe la boxeuse
d'elancourt n'aura pas réussi à se
défaire de la finlandaise me rapporte
connaît on l'a même sans titre est
désemparé à la fin du combat vraiment
elle a expliqué ne pas avoir compris les
décisions des juges
pas de médaille individuelle également
pour guillaume chaîne alors que ses
camarades de l'équipe de france de judo
excellent depuis le début du jeu on les
a vus remporté de nombreuses médailles
le judoka de sartrouville s'est arrêté
lui en 16e de finale face au champion du
monde en titre il aura l'occasion
cependant de se rattraper par équipes
tout ce samedi dès 4 heures du matin
heure française
on suivra ses combats avec attention en
tout cas et parfois il n'y a pas que la
médaille qui compte à l'image de léonie
perriot au triathlon mais exactement
c'était la bonne surprise du début des
jeux un leoni perriot a terminé
cinquième du triathlon féminin
l'athlète de 26 ans finit à seulement 45
secondes du podium
en une heure 57 minutes et 49 secondes
nous la retrouverons également ce samedi
31 juillet
jour de son anniversaire pour l'épreuve
du relais avec 402 beaugrand on souhaite
en tout cas les biennoises un licencié
au club de poissy de remporter une
médaille le jour de son anniversaire
est ce qui nous reste quand même des
chances de médailles bien oui mickaël un
dia des yvelinois qui sont encore en
course pour une médaille c'est le cas de
valentin porte handball l'ailier néo
chesnais et son équipe sont d'ores et
déjà qualifiés pour les quarts de finale
après quatre matches disputés et quatre
victoires en cyclisme sur piste
en plus de tous ceux qui s'entraînent
régulièrement au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 2 illinois de
pure souche seront hantise en lice à
partir du 2 août
il s'agit de clara copponi pour la
poursuite par équipe l'onion et la
madison et florian gringo en vitesse par
équipes
du côté de l'équitation le cavalier de
gaz devant christopher 6 est entrée en
lice cette nuit pour le concours complet
il s'est hissé à la 7e position après
son passage
il reste encore deux épreuves lui et son
cheval totem le cross la nuit de samedi
à dimanche et le saut d'obstacles lundi
prochain enfin celui que nous allons
tous suivre tout le week-end
c'est antoine brothers le golfeur est
toujours en lice dans le coup pour une
médaille
en tout cas on y croit nous un pour
l'instant il est 20e après deux journées
c'est l'un des outsiders du tournoi
michael du coup sûr tout ce qu'il nous
reste vous misez sur combien de
médailles suis de nature optimiste 1 je
dirais une allée deux médailles de
médailles si possible alors pourquoi pas
on l'espère en tout cas on y croit on
merci beaucoup à bixente pour tous ces
résultats à des yvelinois aux jeux
olympiques merci beaucoup et on suivra
avec attention la deuxième semaine des
yvelinois aux jo de tokyo
[Musique]